one of the jokes with my with my my
podcast about Middle School is that I
didn't really I didn't finish Middle
School I didn't I didn't attend high
school so so I um because I was working
and um what age did you uh did you leave
Middle School 12 officially and I was in
seventh grade then okay um didn't finish
my seventh grade year didn't I skipped
eighth grade and started homeschooling
as a ninth grader which was completely
and utterly meaningless
um uh the particular like I don't know
like government assisted program I was
in got a computer
yeah you know um which was the thing
that was you know got a desktop soon
after I took uh a proficiency exam that
gave me the equivalent in California
state to uh to uh to a high school
diploma so I could actually work adult
hours and wouldn't have to do the whole
tutor thing which to be honest was
preferable because it's like when you're
working on set you then have to do these
three hours of you know I've always been
really suspicious of that and I've been
most of my career has been doing uh
obviously working in uh this this
variety format so I haven't I haven't
been exposed to that but the few times
that I've been on a SAT
and I've seen kids leaving to go be
there with their tutor and then uh being
released from the tutor so they can come
back and run away from the dinosaur or
whatever they're supposed to do it
always felt like this can't be great no
it's not yeah yeah it's definitely not
and so you know whatever family
decisions
we were and weren't making I mean my I
think my my mom did make some good if as
long as I was going to go on this path I
actually think it was the right way
because it helped me to remain like
excited to to learn because I was not
having like toxic learning experiences
partly because I didn't finish middle
school or go to high school you know I
actually always have retained the just
utter Joy of reading you know
um oh yeah just like it and and and I
think working also gave me so many
experiences that acted like a another
kind of education so I don't
I mean it's it's weird on one hand I
mean I don't it's it really is my
academic path on paper basically stops
at 12 years old and then but you know
it's interesting because I think uh I
think a love of reading conquers all I
agree with that and um I stumbled upon
this great quote the other day from
Gertrude Stein I don't know who that is
I didn't uh
yeah early modernist uh sure you know uh
helped Hemingway get his start living in
Paris anyway
um but Gertrude Stein said uh
um uh at the end of the day and I'm
misquoting her but basically it was at
the end of the day and education may not
be very important at all and
um I I and I took that to mean it really
is what you
yourself it's it's how you educate
yourself in so many ways uh that can
make up for anything I mean they're
people that have tons of education and
don't know anything and there are people
who educate themselves and I think
reading
is uh just being curious just being
curious about the world and reading
books
um can you know some of the most
brilliant people I've met I don't even
know where they went to college or if
they went to college uh they but their
you know autodidex they just teach
themselves things and
um I'm really in awe of them because
you know in our country obviously we get
really obsessed with
extremely it's you know where'd you go
to school you know and um and I think
there's so much education that you can
do for yourself yeah I mean I I it also
seems to me I mean you went to an
incredible University uh
I feel like ever everybody's report from
from school is
has to do a lot more with life
experience I think right no definitely I
I can't
um one thing everybody knows about me is
that I went to Harvard and I'm I worked
really hard in high school to go there I
was interested in going to a good
college I was really uh I'm proud that I
got in
um I can't tell you what I learned there
uh that I retained today what I remember
of the people I remember meeting lots of
interesting people some of who many of
whom are still my friends to this day I
remembered getting interested in comedy
I was always interested in comedy but
finding an outlet for it there I'm very
clear I'm very clear with my kids that
uh uh it was not
it's not Hogwarts you don't go to these
schools and they impart some magical
spells to you that then take you on in
life and you're a great sorcerer
um and you get an owl I'm going to keep
going with this okay please uh and uh
you know Snape's involved
um okay I think it's I'd like to hear
more I don't know I don't get this every
day so I know you I know you're sick of
it there are different houses you know
how many well it's interesting you say
there's there's
[Laughter]
but um but I do think it's you know and
like I say I I think one of the great my
great education in my life has been uh
stumbling around making mistakes in the
real world humiliating myself having
some things go well some things go
terribly uh that has been my education
and I I'm you know I do I sometimes feel
badly that uh we have this
there's all this pressure on kids today
I think that you you know that uh there
are certain schools that have the golden
key yeah and you if you don't get to
those schools you cannot move forward
and I think of all my heroes who
didn't go to school or went to a school
I I don't know or were terrible students
flunked out
and they have you know achieved
spectacular things and it's it's another
thing
that would probably come up on your
podcast because I I see it so much as
how much pressure there is on 15 16 17
18 year olds you know to schools are so
much more competitive now than they were
yeah when I was applying I don't think
I'd get into any of these schools now
they're they're uh it's amazing and
they're coming kids you know kids are
competing against everybody they're
competing against the very best kids in
the entire world and China and India and
it is very very very difficult and I
think it's it's a lot of pressure for a
really young kid to have it really is
and then also once you get out and I
mean what just the relevance of a degree
now and just how many I don't even know
you know people say something like do
people say the job market anymore is
that a I mean I feel like I used to hear
that a lot I used to hear it but now now
after covet it's like
no one's something no one has said job
market in three years
I don't know why we're laughing
everything's crumbling around us that's
the pain yeah